STEPHANIE WONG: Today, we're
talking about reCAPTCHA,
self-service security
analytics, autonomous vehicles,
and Climate TRACE.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
ReCAPTCHA Enterprise is Google's
online fraud detection service
that leverages over a
decade of experience
defending the internet.
ReCAPTCHA Enterprise
can be used to prevent
fraud and attacks
perpetrated by scripts,
bot software, or humans.
As a part of our
continued investment here,
we're announcing Account
Defender in public preview.
It's a new feature built into
reCAPTCHA Enterprise that
helps you determine if an
action aligns or deviates
from the account owner's
typical behavior.
As more organizations
embrace the principles
of autonomic
security operations,
we continue to
research and develop
new initiatives
that can simplify
the adoption of
continuous detection
and continuous response
workflows for security
operations teams.
To this end, we're excited to
announce Community Security
Analytics, a set of open source
queries and rules designed
for self-service security
analytics designed
to help detect common
cloud-based threats.
As we continue to explore
climate solutions using machine
learning in our "People and
Planet" AI YouTube series,
we have been blown away by
an amazing project called
Climate TRACE.
It's a collaborative
data-sharing effort
across 50-plus organizations
with the intention of helping
the public, for free, to view
where carbon pollution is
emitted by country
and even by industry
in a meaningful and
visual way as a web app.
Learn more and check out
the video in the blog.
Cruise has been focused
on tackling city driving
since 2013, and with more than
3 million autonomous miles
under our belt,
we're getting closer
to delivering an all-electric
shared self-driving service.
In January 2002, we reached
a major milestone-- members
of the public took their very
first fully driverless rides
in San Francisco.
Developing an urban fleet
of fully autonomous vehicles
is an incredible challenge.
To be successful, we needed
to build both the AV tech
that's out on the road
and the ecosystem of tools
our engineers use internally.
Check out the blog for more.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.